Hi Sonja, I think it's only you at the moment.
Hi Michelle, I'm just eating my late breakfast.
Go right ahead, just know that I'm here when you're ready.
You can go. I mean if it's just us and you're happy to watch me eat I can just come on.
Oh well, entirely up to you. There's only the two of us so it's not like any lines being crossed Sonja.
Right here you go. And I'm just a bit like grossed out by people eating.
Well I think there's so many things that people, like I just don't understand that after all this time of using Zoom or Teams or any of these things,
people are still so unaware when they've got their camera on, aren't they?
I've just been on, I was just doing my meditation teacher training for like 12 weeks. So it was like a Zoom twice a week.
And there was one woman who just like wouldn't put herself on mute and her kids would just run in screaming and she'd be a little bit like, oh they cute kind of thing and it was like, no, like it's rude.
And it's a meditation training.
Exactly.
It could have been more distracting.
Yeah, I was just sort of stunned by the lack of self-awareness.
And also like I'm very, I think it comes from leading a big team in corporate. I'm so like aware of stuff like that.
Like I'm child free, which is what I wanted. But you never know what other people are doing or going through.
Like, you know, if there's someone on the call is on like the sixth round of IVF, I'm always also just like, don't put it in people's faces.
Like you don't know what the deal is.
Yeah.
I couldn't agree more. Could not agree more.
So I don't know. This is a little unusual that nobody is here.
So was there something that you wanted to talk about today in particular?
Or we just kick in with people?
Yeah, I was just going to do a bit of a check in. I'm, I'm, I finished my first draft, which is probably like the big news since the last call.
I went into like a real lighting frenzy. I was in Bali for a month.
And so I've been starting to explore with publishers.
I'm speaking to Wiley, Alan and Unwin.
And what's the name of that lovely man who does this self-publishing, the grammar factory?
Oh, yes, Scott.
To kind of explore those as options.
So I'm through to the, whatever the final round is with Wiley, where they kind of have the final meeting.
So I think I'll get like a go, no go with a contract or not to look at like in the next week or so, or they'll say no.
And fighting to be at that stage. That's very exciting.
Yeah, to be honest, it was a real shock because I had got in touch with Jordan and I actually was even going to explore traditional publishers.
Because I just didn't think they'd be interested. And then someone encouraged me to, and I had my first meeting with her and I was kind of thinking,
I'll pitch it. Nothing will come of it, but it's good to have the opportunity to see how the process works, you know, see what kind of questions that they ask.
And she just, she kind of asked me a few questions and then she just started walking through the process and I was a bit like, oh, this is weird.
And then she just said, yeah, we really like it.
I think like the timing is good for and stuff. So I want to take into the publishing meeting.
And so that's been kind of going through the process for about a month. And then I had another contact that Alan and I'm when I sent the proposal to her and she asked for, she's asked for some writing samples.
And I'm a bit like just working out which chapters to send.
So I need to send in the next 24 hours or so.
Okay.
Because it's also obviously I've only got like the dirty draft. So it's like, I kind of need to polish up a couple.
I don't know. I mean, what do you think? Like, what's your kind of.
That's that's really interesting.
Because I remember Lisa Taylor being in that situation and having the conversation with her.
But she had a direct, a directive from the publisher. She said, send me your introduction.
And then one or two chapters.
Okay.
Because I think, yeah, it's really understanding the importance of that first grab.
Have you done any?
Oh, I've written the whole thing. Yeah.
So you do have an introduction ready to go?
I do have an introduction.
I sent her the prologue initially and she said, I like it. Send me more.
Because it's a little the prologues. It's very short. It's a couple of pages.
So I thought it'd be a good thing to send because it's a little like vignette of actually park,
which is the my grandparents meeting kind of as the reason for the book.
So she was like, I like this.
So yeah, I think I've been, I actually plugged everything into Claude and said,
what do you reckon? And it told me which three chapters it thought I should send.
But yeah, I need to, I, it's in, I'm in that weird place where I haven't even had any beta readers.
So it's a bit like scary just sending it to an editor.
But I suppose it has to do it.
I think you do just have to do it.
Yeah.
I've sent it to a few friends like they've started.
So I've got people kind of starting to go through it now.
I've got people who I kind of opinion I respect.
But yeah, I can't, I'm just on Wednesday.
So I've given myself Monday morning as the time when I need to send it.
Yeah. Okay. Okay. Did she ask for table of contents?
Well, I've already sent her the book proposal.
Oh, okay. So yeah.
Which has the, it has quite a, you use it.
Yeah. Yeah.
Okay.
Good.
I've, I tweaked it a little bit.
Yeah. It's pretty much that one.
So it's got quite a detailed,
and my chapter summaries are quite detailed because I've got like all the,
it's got like who the interviews are with and the stories and that kind of thing.
So you can tell quite a lot from it.
Yeah. It just feels a bit weird.
Like I kind of, it's sort of gone from like,
like obviously I was initially like, oh, you'll never be able to write this.
And then I thought you'll never be able to publish this.
And then now I've got all these new fears of like,
what if I've accidentally plagiarized someone or like, what if I haven't like,
you know, kind of reference something properly or what if it's just like terrible?
Look, you know what?
That's kind of some self editing that you can be doing once a decision is made.
Yeah. And I know once it's made, like I've got.
I've never asked my dad for motion to sport my whole life and he's English, right?
And I actually messaged him saying, God, I feel really anxious about this.
And he said, oh, from what I've read, it's quite good and you've got a process like,
these are retired actually.
So I'm getting him to check it for logic.
Okay. So make sure that it's like, yeah, I kind of have got a plan,
but it's just weird that it sort of is starting to feel like it could actually happen.
Celebrate that. Yeah.
Sonia, it is such a milestone.
And remember, this is part of becoming a published author.
Yeah.
You know, feeling that the question might be, oh,
have you really put enough time and care into this?
Yeah.
But I have just been reading this.
The business of being an author.
Yeah.
Yeah. Okay.
Andrew Griffiths.
Somebody posted something in Circle a while ago and I didn't,
I didn't read it.
I have to go back and read it.
Do you know him at all?
You come across? No.
So he's been involved with the Australian Business Book Awards
and there is, he's an international bestselling business author.
He's Australian.
I think he's from Tasman.
Hello.
Hi, Nina.
Hi, sorry I'm late.
That's okay.
We're just a small group.
So great to see you.
Yeah.
I'm talking about Andy Griffiths, Andrew Griffiths book.
Oh, okay.
The Business of Being an Author.
He's published 18 books.
He's Australian.
Do I say that?
Yeah.
And for example, in the front,
there's a testimonial from Michael Hanrahan,
who's really the founder and managing director of the Australian
Business Book Awards,
of which Anna Featherstone has been a judge and I think Kelly
might have been at some stage.
And there's a lot in here about author mindset,
Sonia.
And there's a lot about,
I mean, it's a really great resource, can I say,
in terms of what were some of the chapters I was highlighting
to talk about today.
So assessing your book objectivity.
There's a checklist.
Avoiding common author mistakes,
which is a lot around mindset.
Remembering that your book is an extraordinary resource.
So there's a lot in there about how you're going to use your
book.
But one of the things that I was just reading was becoming a
student of books.
So he talks about going into a bookstore and looking at books
that might be in your category and taking everything in,
from the cover, the colour, the design, the font.
What's all of that cover?
Then he says, go to the table of contents and really does
it make sense.
So the reason I'm saying this is when you go back to your
book, this is what publishes a book.
This is what publishes are doing.
Because he says, think like a publisher.
Does the introduction, is that enough for me to want to
read further?
I turn to the table of contents.
Is that speaking to me?
Can I see the logic of the flow?
Can I see what's happening here?
And then so on.
If you look at enough other books and you know what you
like and you see what works, then you come back to
the course.
Yeah.
If only is, I read so much and it's mostly novels.
Yeah, obviously.
And the nonfiction books I read are things like, you
know, Rikka's Brennan and stuff that's like very above
my capability.
I guess I was saying read the whole book.
Yeah, just look at the contents.
Yeah.
It's interesting.
It helps you make decisions.
And it's always coming back to, as he says, like we all
say, why have you written it?
What's the premise?
And who's it for?
Yeah.
Who's it for?
And if those things are tying together and then you
decide which three chapters you send.
So you've sent a lot of detail about your contents.
And then a preface that's introducing the back story,
so to speak.
And you've got three chapters, but Claude, but if you've
put enough of your, if you've given Claude enough
instruction as to what chapters you're wanting, then
you know, go with that.
The absence of...
I mean, I have to send it like one way or another.
I mean, that's right.
I still have no choice.
That's right.
Yeah.
It's an exciting step.
Oh, that's right.
I know why I picked this up for you.
There's a lot in mindset.
And you've got to, you know, just keep remembering why
you're doing this, Sonia.
Why have you put all this effort into it?
And trust yourself.
Trust yourself and keep going.
The fact that you've gotten to this step with Wiley
and Anne-Lyn and Alan are asking you for more.
This is great.
They celebrated.
Yeah, it's funny with, like with some of the people that
have been interviewing, like academics and stuff, I've been
so nervous about approaching them and they might actually
speak to them and they're going to take, like it's
almost that you can't have to realign your self-image
of yourself.
Which I am finding a bit of a struggle, but it's a
gradual process, I suppose.
Yes, but I think it's also, yeah, and everyone,
everyone moves through that at their own pace, of course.
But if you don't start moving forward,
you won't have the book in your hand.
That's true.
Look at popping up these reasons.
Yeah.
You, Nina, where are you at with all of this?
Okay.
I've sent my book to two publishers.
Yep.
So, and I had two publishers that wanted to read
the manuscript.
Yeah.
So I had a conversation with someone from the EAC
last week and I said, should I be sending this
off to two publishers?
And she said, well, why don't you do send it
to both and then get the feedback from both.
And I've had long conversations with the kind press.
Yep.
And the other person is outside of the EAC,
which is Bernadette Foley from Broad Sheet Books.
Yeah.
Broad Sheet Books.
So, and I've met with her in person and had
conversations with her about my book.
So that's where I'm at.
Yeah.
So, tell me, Bernadette, I'm pretty sure.
Have you looked at her catalogue?
Yep.
You've done other cancer story books.
Do you know?
Not really, but she's done a lot of personal
experience pieces.
Yeah.
Nice.
Okay.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Okay.
Good.
I did research because I do know somebody here in Sydney
who is, who works in that space and knows who's who in the zoo.
Yeah.
And just said to me that she's somebody that can be trusted
and she's got a really great network and that sort of thing.
She, and I looked at who does her PR,
the girl that does her PR has written a book
about living as a expat in Hong Kong herself.
I can't think, recall a name at the moment.
Oh, I know.
Yeah.
It's like a blonde in Hong Kong.
She was a Channel 10 journalist.
Yep.
Oh God, what's her name?
Yeah.
I used her for my PR.
Oh, did you?
Yeah.
This, yeah.
Blonde.
Oh my goodness.
And I really, I really liked her approach to PR.
Yeah.
And the, yeah.
So I don't know.
And I had a long conversation with Natasha about my book.
So I've spoken to them.
They, and I'm just waiting for four months.
I'm just waiting for feedback from both about their thoughts on
my book.
Natasha and I spoke a lot about the legal aspects of my book
where I haven't had that conversation with Bernadette.
So I'm just waiting for both to come back with first their
opinion.
Yeah.
And second, how they would see the process.
And I want the, and I've told both, I do want the opportunity to
launch in England next year.
Oh, okay.
So I do, and I've got no contacts there.
I don't even like, I can, I have got a friend that is on the
ground, but I don't really have any contacts there.
But besides distributing the book through Amazon, you know,
how might I, how might I do that?
So you would have had that discussion with Natasha?
Yeah.
I've already had that discussion with Natasha.
So you know how, like, if you have a look at Sophie Breitang's
book, she seems to be everywhere.
I know.
So the kind press have a different distribution arrangement.
Of course, since harsh course they do.
I missed out on the stuff.
I just got the collapse of booktopia.
Anyway.
So I think that's come a long way since, you know, in the two years
since I published with the kind press.
So that's a tick for you.
I don't know about Bernardette's distribution.
Do you, does she have an affiliation with anyone for
distribution?
Well, she used to work for Penguin.
So she, she knows she look, I have to understand this a little
bit better.
Yeah.
She, she basically said, I can't, I'm not even going to recall
this very well.
That it's about the distributor having relationships with
various book shops and, and so, and getting the offer into those
book shops in front of readers.
So she talked about that, which is multiple book signings and,
and, and I think that's linked to the whole PR piece.
Well, it is, it is.
Yeah.
And I think, look, it just comes back to, and this is
something for you to consider Sonia.
Yeah.
If you're thinking about the grammar factory, then as I
understand it, there isn't any distribution.
They're really a public, you know, they're really doing the
publishing.
Yes.
Print on demand.
He said like you can, yeah, you can basically go and
pitch it yourself to book shops.
I don't know how realistic that is.
You know how hard that is.
Yeah.
So I think that
I'm going to go back to the question because I had, I had a
conversation with White Sox as well in London.
It's the same thing.
Like I think they're really good quality editing and stuff,
but it's print on demand.
So yeah, I think I know everyone talks about all the
pitfalls of traditional publishing, but I think that is
my preference.
What about, did Andrew go with Hardy Grant?
Andrew Sloan.
Yeah.
What, who did he go with?
I'm trying to remember.
Yeah.
Hardy Grant.
Andrew went with Hardy Grant.
Yeah.
And then they have three parts to their business.
Traditional, custom and media.
Yeah.
Okay.
So he's gone with the custom.
I'm, I'm as and Fay Evans.
Do you remember Fay Nina?
Yeah.
She's about, I can't remember her book.
Self or simplicity.
Yes.
Yeah.
So she started to publish and she started to
publish and she's with Hardy Grant.
And I think Penelope went with the customer of Hardy Grant
as well.
Oh yeah.
So let's speak to Penelope actually.
She gave me a number because she was just going to
share her experiences.
But I've been away for months.
I had a chance.
I'm speaking to Andrew next week.
I'm trying to get like as many and cat page he did
Wiley just to kind of get some experiences.
Oh, Hardy Grant is at the top end of the
the author investment in the project.
Yeah.
Okay.
What does that look like?
That's a nice way to put it in the shell.
Because I've heard this.
How much are we talking?
Very ballpark.
Okay.
Well, a couple of years ago when, so before
Hush was published, the offer I had from them
was about 22,000.
I think you can add another 10 to that from what I've heard.
For now.
Okay.
So I'm talking probably three years ago now.
Wow.
So it's, so yeah.
So, so it's, I imagine it would be more than that now.
And does that include distribution?
Well, no, not really.
Okay.
It includes.
So distribution is a different, is another stream of all of this.
The thing about traditional publishing is that they are part of
the distribution stream.
So that relationships with DemiX and, I don't know,
what are the other big bookstores?
I don't know.
Readings.
Yeah.
That's my local bookshop.
The independent bookstores of which there are many is a
very different, very different ballgame.
But what sits in between publishing and bookstores is the
distributors.
And there's only really two that just do distribution in
Australia.
I think one is Woods Lane.
And the other ones are Man's Name, which I could never
remember.
But it's in the, it's in the, if you go into the resources,
and if it's not in the EAC, or anyway, it doesn't matter
because typically authors aren't dealing directly with
distributors, right?
Yeah.
So then it depends which, which one of those your
customer or hybrid publisher might have a relationship
with.
Now, when I published the kind press had a relationship
with Booktopia.
And that's what I was, I went, that sounds good.
Because Booktopia was doing quite well then.
And then of course it wasn't so good for me.
They now have a different, and Booktopia collapsed and
was bought out and now operates very differently.
But as I understand it, now they use Simon and
Schuster now for distribution.
Is that right?
The kind press.
Yeah.
I think, I think that's a good thing, right?
Sounds like a good thing because it's been a good
thing for Sophie.
I know that.
It's certainly been a good thing for Sophie.
I know.
Sophie's on fire.
She is on fire.
And of course her title is so aligned with the kind press.
Yes.
Which, you know, how could she have not gone down that path.
But distribution is really, if you're thinking about
Fasonia, if you're thinking about that, that.
The fact that, you know, your English and your folks are
still there and so on, then obviously it makes sense.
And then, you know, I think that's a good thing for
distribution.
Your folks are still there and so on.
Then obviously it makes sense that you would think about
distribution in Britain.
Yeah.
Nina, I'm not sure what your connections are, but it is a
question that you need to make sure that you're asking
whoever you're speaking with, whether it's traditional or
hybrid publishing.
And you need, when you're looking at your contract,
really try and see what is in there about distribution.
Yeah.
Because something that we, it's never spoken about.
You kind of assume that if you're publishing with someone,
whether it be custom or traditional, that distribution
is taken care of.
And the fact of the matter is, it's not always.
Yeah.
And so things like your local bookstore or any independent
bookstores.
So what happens is there is a big database.
Once you've got an ISBN number, your logged in,
you're logged into this massive database.
And I was trying to find some statistics this week about how
many Australian business books are published a year.
And I couldn't find it, of course, for this year because
we're still in this year.
But it's hundreds of, you know, like it's many, many
thousands, many, many thousands.
Bookstores can't take every book.
So this is when publishers send out salespeople and
going back to your point earlier, Nina, about who has
the relationships with which bookstores.
That's when you're kind of relying on those relationships
to get your book into a bookstore.
So we're...
Yeah.
And then it's understanding what that process looks like.
Because I've spoken to a lot of authors inside the EAC
and outside the EAC first-time authors.
And the challenge seems to be, yes, I can get it.
Yes, it's in the bookstore.
And if it doesn't sell, it's coming back to me.
And this is the thing.
So the reason that independent bookstores don't take
self-published authors, and essentially that's what a high-brid
broadcaster is, is because if they don't sell them,
what are they going to do with them?
Whereas if it's a traditional publisher, they just box them up
and send them out.
Oh, is that how it works?
Yeah.
I didn't realise that.
OK.
So that's what I'm hearing from the people that have
had distribution.
And Michelle, also what I'm hearing in conversation with...
And it's just from people's experience is...
And you might know more about this, is getting clear about the
numbers because apparently it's really hard to get...
Like for instance, Sophie has apparently sold 2,000 books
in a short time.
Right, crazy.
Yeah, very crazy.
It's so good, right?
So then I'm hearing from other authors...
Oh, I'm really not clear on my numbers because I'm asking
people about numbers and people are saying,
well, I'm not clear because it's been distributed through
this network, but we don't know if it's going to come back
or not.
All of that.
So I'm guessing that a lot of Sophie's numbers are based on
what she's been selling at her book launches and her events.
Yeah, OK.
And so...
So if you...
If you're on...
So it's going to be on Amazon anyway.
There's only...
Here's the thing.
If you set up...
If you self-publish and you set up your own account
on Amazon, then you can go in it to the author portal at any time
and check your numbers.
Right.
If you're with any kind of hybrid publisher or traditional
publisher where that's all been done for you, then it's a
little trickier in numbers.
And I remember having this conversation with Charlotte Blair,
who by the way, Sonya published with the grammar factory.
OK.
And what was her book슷?
Career Unstuck.
Something like that.
Yeah, Career Unstuck.
Career Unstuck.
And she was having a lot of trouble getting the Amazon figures.
And so publishers get them quarterly.
And you'll get a breakdown between the Kindle version
and the Kindle audio or print.
But remember that you're getting maybe, I don't know,
$2 a book or something once it's gone through that whole process.
Yeah?
So if you independently take your book to an independent
bookshop and they say, well, we'll take 10, then you know...
And then you sell 10 because you'll get a commission
directly from that bookstore, then you've got your Excel
spreadsheet and you pump in 10.
So you know where you're at.
With the wider distribution through publishing,
you might get that quarterly or half-yearly.
That they're waiting to see how many books are returned
and all of that kind of stuff's going on in the background.
You can be at least six months behind in getting numbers.
Yeah, OK.
The only way to know your own numbers is a few
website selling at it, the NST and all that kind of stuff.
Yeah, I know it's a total maze.
It is a maze.
And yeah.
And so, you know, publishers are very keen to keep control of all of that.
When I'm talking about the Wileys of the world and so on, the traditional publishers,
because it's important for them to be able to talk about their numbers.
Hmm.
But again, coming back to Andrew Griffiths and what he's, what he talks about in here,
which is coming back to why you're publishing a book.
So, you think about besides bookstores, how else are you going to distribute it?
What do you want to do with it? Why is it?
So, if you think about Mellow, and I always come back to Mellow,
because I always think of the Iceland.
I remember when he had to send many books to a client in Iceland
and how much it was going to cost him to get them printed there and all the rest of it.
So, Sonja, he'd publish with Wileys.
But all of this is happening later.
So, even with a traditional publisher, after three months, this stuff, you know,
you go down the list of priority of these sort of questions.
But he does big events.
So, he's speaking to big audiences.
And so, he will maybe in the fee for the event include a copy for everybody.
Yeah.
So, the client in that case is paying for the book.
But in his numbers, that's another 250 books to say.
Yeah.
I'm just making up that number.
But he does a lot of those events.
Andrew Griffiths in here, he's talking about using his...
He says, at the moment...
So, this book, he self-published through a custom publisher called Publishing Central.
I thought, oh, that's a bit interesting.
So, I went and had a look at them to see what they charge.
Again, it was getting up to the 20,000.
But it's a book that he uses as a business card, if you like.
Yeah.
Whereas if he's doing another book at the moment, and it's all in here,
where it's more about creating some new IP and wanting wider distribution and so on.
So, he's doing it with Wiley.
So, he says, different books for different reasons, different publishing pathways.
Yeah.
Anyway, it's all in the book.
So, that's worth thinking about.
Yeah.
If you're the keynote speaking, selling it from the back of the room.
And of course, what happens then?
Let's say the RRP is $35 and you sell at the back of the room for $30.
You're still, you're better off than counting your numbers on Amazon.
The thing with Amazon is, if someone Googles you, here's about you.
You want your book to be, you want it to be held somewhere for those random people.
And for the people.
Yes.
And tap the reviews.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Absolutely.
So, you know, again, it's what do you want your book to do?
What are you going to be doing?
I'm still selling my book at in-person events and I'm selling it for $30.
Because, you know, just like, it was really hard to get it into bookstores.
The booktopia thing happened.
And so, I'm using it for, as a business card.
Well, I'm not giving, I'll give them away as he says.
You give them to people who are likely, who you're wanting to convert to a new client.
So, if you're meeting someone one-on-one and it's a, I'll take a book with me.
I'll give them a book.
But if it's an event, so for example, the writing programs, if they sign up for a writing workshop,
part of that fee to sign up, they get a copy.
But they've actually been, if they get a copy.
But those figures aren't going to turn up in the kind press's numbers or they're not going to turn up in the Nielsen data do the thingy.
Because those numbers aren't recorded anywhere.
Other than when I order some books from the kind press.
So, all, and they'll all operate differently and charge you differently.
And again, that stuff, Nina, is going to be in your contract.
Both of you.
So, with Wiley, Sonia, I think, I'm trying to think Jackie Clark's another one that published with Wiley.
I spoke to Graham as well.
Graham Cowan published his last one with Wiley.
He had a really good experience with them actually.
He was quite happy.
I remember seeing his book a lot at the time, like a bit of the airport have you and it was, they seem to really push his actually, but then he's obviously got a great platform and story and, you know, doing a UK and everything else.
But it's worth asking them how many they had to buy?
Yes.
Because I think, if I'm thinking about Mello and Jackie, I reckon it was probably a thousand or something like that.
Yeah.
Which, you know.
Oh yeah, I'm getting the feel like there's a cost involved because.
Absolutely, there's a cost involved.
Yeah.
Nicole, Nicole, is that is that PR person?
Isn't it Nina?
Nicole.
The PR person you were talking about.
Yeah.
Nicole, what's her surname?
I'm just going to have a look.
Nicole.
Why is that not in my phone?
Wait a minute.
I'll just look it up myself.
I mean, I'll look it up as well.
So I think, did Graham use another PR person, Sonya?
Do you know?
As well as whatever came out of the Wiley.
I can't remember what he said.
I'm not sure that he did.
So Wiley doesn't have in-house PR, which they've been quite upfront with me about.
They kind of talked about the market, like Jordan talked about the marketing and stuff.
So I'm, yeah, I'm kind of into minds.
I've got, it's my background was that for about 10 years.
So I've got some, I've got some friends that I, but I don't think I'm particularly good at publicity these days and I haven't got the right connections.
But I might see if I can call in a favor and do like a mate's rate gig or a contra gig with one of my mates that I kind of rate high for it.
Like I need to, I'm kind of like once I've got the deal and the timeline, but yeah, that was going to be my plan because I just don't think I can justify another.
It sounds like it'd be like 10 grand potentially.
Well, Scott Aethorn I now is, I think now is up to 12.
Yeah.
Three months.
Nicole Webb.
Nicole Webb. Thank you.
China Blonde was her book.
Yeah.
That's what probably 10 years ago now.
Nicole Webb.
Yeah.
The book.
Oh, here we go.
And do you know how much she costs Nina?
I don't.
I don't know.
Three to five.
But she doesn't have the.
So she's quite good for some, maybe Nina's book.
But she doesn't.
Not for mine.
Yeah.
Books as such.
Sonya Scott only does business books.
He doesn't do memoir, anything memoir based.
Yeah.
Not his geek.
The other day.
The other person who's amazing actually for more social impact stuff is Odette.
Have you come across Odette?
She's, yeah, her company's called like Odette and Co.
Something like that.
And she's just brilliant.
She's really, really good at.
Yeah.
And I think kind of social impact.
I know around the trap she's based in Byron,
but she runs like a national agency.
Okay.
Yep.
So I think investigate any of those connections that you have.
Sarah Gray.
She didn't use anybody.
She got it.
She met or used.
Now what's her name?
Heidi Anderson.
And I came across her on Instagram.
Through the week.
And she was offering a webinar.
And it's kind of like why spend 30,000 on PR when you can do it yourself.
Or why spend 30,000 on a publicist when you can do it yourself.
That's right.
And she was selling her program,
which I think is probably around a thousand or 1500,
something like that.
Or you can engage her to do it for you.
So if you have a look at her website,
you can find her on the website.
You can engage her to do it for you.
So if you have a look at her website,
Sarah, I think did the,
she got all the,
the tricks and the cheat sheets and did all the stuff from Heidi.
And then did, so did the grunt work herself.
Do you know Sarah Sonia?
No.
What was her name?
Sarah Gray.
So her.
The neighbouring subelbe.
I don't know her.
No, her I would say.
Very men of course.
Yeah.
Is it's not you?
It's very many.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
I know of it.
Yes.
I know.
It's a good title.
She's been on.
I think the Channel 7 or the Channel 9 morning.
What are they called today or whatever it's called?
One of those shows.
Yeah.
She's been on radio and that turned into a kind of a semi
permanent gig.
She's been in body and soul.
So she, so I just emailed her and said how did you find Heidi?
Is it worth mentioning her in the EAC?
Because Heidi was using Sonia as a testimonial in this
webinar, which I'm assuming Sarah.
You're saying Sarah.
Yeah.
I'm assuming Sarah is given a position for.
Oh.
I think she's been in body and soul.
So she, so I just emailed her and said how did you find
her?
But that's a do it yourself.
So you're spending what?
$1,500 getting, I think.
You're getting introductions and stuff for that.
Did you say 1,500 or 1,500?
1,500.
Okay.
That's not bad.
But that's, so you're getting all the stuff, but then
you're doing it yourself.
And so that Sarah's feedback was, you know, like I
think Sarah's done quite well actually by doing it
herself and she saved that money.
So there are other ways of doing it, but it's worth
having an email, Sarah through the EAC.
If you want to find out more about that.
I've asked Heidi to, I, Sarah did an intro for me
with Heidi and I've asked her to, can we have a
conversation?
And she hasn't come back to me.
She just wanted to offer, you know, come and do a
thing and then sell her stuff to the EAC and that we
don't kind of operate that way.
I'd prefer to, I just wanted to kind of have a chat to
her before I talk to Kelly about it.
But it's, you know, I just have a look at her
website and maybe have a chat to Sarah if you
think that's the way that you want to go, which
for Sonia might work for you given that you've
got a lot of history there.
Yeah.
Between publicity and marketing, like it's quite a
different gig.
And I think publicity is really hard.
I think people underestimate how difficult it is.
So even though I've got a background in it, and I
was seeing very different.
I was seeing like corporate PR, like it's very
different.
I would still want some guidance because I also
think it's very difficult to do anything like this
on yourself.
Like I think it's good to objectively be like
these, this is the story for you.
And I think if someone could help me work through
that, I could probably pitch it myself.
But also just, I think, you know, objective views
on like media targets and that kind of thing is
really helpful.
Yeah, absolutely.
And I think, I think whoever you use, you've
kind of got to get your head around the fact that
it's for three months.
Yeah.
Which is going to be pre-launched a month
before, during the launch, and then a month after
that kind of, that month of launch.
Then you're on your own.
Yeah.
And so this is, I think, this post-publishing, this
is when it gets really exhausting.
Really, your mind just moves into this other gear
of numbers, distribution, PR, marketing.
Oh wow, I've just had the email from Jordan
saying they want to offer me September 2027
publication.
Oh, okay.
Wow, congratulations.
Later than I would have wanted, but I'll have a look
at the offer.
Okay, that's exciting.
It's very exciting.
But I think this is the thing to get your head
around is that traditional publishing is going to
be a 12 month exercise.
This is the one in the other.
Yeah.
If you want six months, I pushed it to four
because I wanted, I had a date in mind.
And, you know, that's probably the only thing I
regret.
And that was me.
But was the publishers kind of like, no, we need
at least six.
And I'm like, no, no, I want it to be Mother's
Day.
Yeah, yeah.
So I completely wear that myself.
Very exciting.
Have a look.
Wow.
How does that work for you, September 27?
Oh, yeah, like it's totally fine.
I think I had in my head, it'd be good to go earlier
next year, but that's not really based on anything
or any particular, like it might be good to do
12 months proper run up to it, to be honest.
Yeah.
Publicity, they're going to, you know, they're
going to want to start at least a month before,
at least.
Is that like 12 months of me trying to get on
pod, like actually saying I've got a publication
date and getting on podcasts and getting people,
you know, all of that kind of thing.
And I think like, time in us, it's still fine.
Because also what I'm writing about is also like a
little bit random.
So I don't, well, I don't know.
It's kind of interesting because I felt like
there's lots of stuff starting to come out
about collaboration and working together and
stuff now.
We can still be talking about that.
Yeah.
And obviously the way I'm writing it is a bit
different.
My God.
Can I ask, that must be so exciting.
Can I ask Sonja, have you had any conversation
about when the best time is to publish your
book?
I have.
No, I have not.
Yeah.
Okay.
Can I just say really quickly, I've only just
noticed your wallpaper and that is beautiful.
Thank you.
I absolutely love the hat.
I might message you on the chat.
I'm going to go to the chat.
I absolutely love the hat.
I might message you after to find out where it's
from.
I want to do like a feature wall in my, anyway,
sorry, I'm digressing, but yeah, please,
sorry, timing for publishing.
Yeah.
Ready to talk?
Yeah, because Michelle, this is something
that I'm finding very interesting and I got
quite a lot of guidance on this from the
Kind Press.
Yeah.
And now I can't remember.
Yours was near the end of the year, wasn't it?
Your book was launched.
Mine was Mother's Day.
And that's because there's that mother.
Yeah.
Well, Natasha, Natasha actually said to me,
because my book has an element of self-help,
like there's a lot of exercises around self-help
and values and all that sort of thing.
I kind of thought end year.
And then she said to me something very interesting.
She said the end of the year is the true self-help
books where you get to January and everyone's
laying on the beach and they want life to look
different and there's like 10 ways to do this.
And she said those books sell.
Now, I'm not quoting her.
This is not quote unquote, but this is how
the conversation went.
And then she said, then when people get back to work
and that they start to want to be entertained
because maybe all of those goals didn't quite take off.
So it's like we'll start reading novels and that sort of thing.
And then she said your book is when it starts to get colder
and people want more deep reading.
So she actually said to me, May, June, July.
Yeah.
So I thought that was interesting.
It made sense to me.
Oh, absolutely.
And if you think about, I mean,
often people think something like your book or my book, even.
Yeah.
Maybe not so much our books, I guess,
but memoir and a lot of those kind of,
a lot of people want to be in the market for Christmas.
Yeah.
That's what I was thinking.
And then I was thinking all the celebrity cookbooks come out.
Yeah.
All the cricketers, autobiographies come out for Christmas.
Like there's so much going on in that Christmas market.
Yeah.
You need to hook it to a date if you can.
Same thing about publicity.
Like I missed an opportunity.
So one of the things that Heidi was saying in her memoir was
whenever you're pitching your book,
if you can,
that one of the easiest things to do is to find one of those
international day of the month of.
And because journalists,
any journalist, whether it be, you know, magazines, podcasts, TV,
whatever it is,
they're always looking for content.
And so they're always looking for content around these days.
So what I didn't realize until the 30th of August was that
August is the international year of grief and grieving.
And the day was the 31st.
And I know this because I had a marketing email that come to me
and I've gone, oh man, I missed an opportunity,
but I've made a note for next year.
So funny enough, my friend Celia, who runs a PR agency,
was one of the people I was going to maybe ask for help.
She put together a,
it was a bit of a like,
he up, PRing her own business because it's some of its DIY PR,
but she has actually put together a calendar of all of those days
and months that is freely available.
So I'll post in the group about it because yeah,
people are going to do,
I don't know if she's, she definitely did it two years in a row.
I don't know if it's up to date for this year or for next year,
but it kind of doesn't matter because you'd be able to just go through
and see all of the past days and you can always double check them.
But exactly for that, because that's like that.
If you're doing your own PR, that's the easiest way to do it
because you look at all of the hooks you could use in a year
and how you reissue it.
Yeah.
Exactly.
So Nina, you've just missed Effadil Day.
Yeah.
Um, which is interesting.
So Daffodil Day, so we're in, I don't, I don't even know what day it is, honestly.
Um, sorry.
I know.
Where has the year gone?
Is my question.
I know.
It's very scary when it gets to August.
It's always very scary.
Yeah.
So September.
Have we had it or is it still in September?
But it doesn't matter.
You can still post this year about it.
I mean, that's the point.
Is that it's, it's finding the story in your book and finding a connection
with one of these days.
And.
And you can, you know, even if you don't get it to a PR person, it can still be
a LinkedIn or an Insta post, wherever your choice of posts.
So again, sorry to come back to mellow, but had a conversation with him
yesterday.
So he's front of mind.
Because of the nature of his book, he's always very busy during are you okay
week?
Just next week.
And he's got something like he's got events on every day because his
book content is so, so well suited to that.
Um, Sarah Martin with DSI cosis and now her second one, dear carer
always gets a lot of stuff happening around.
Are you okay day?
Yeah, that would be she's completely traditionally public self
published completely self published.
Do all the PR and stuff herself.
Oh, she had a friend.
So here are some things that you can be doing now.
Anyway, but I do agree with Natasha's kind of that makes that
makes sense to me about times of the year.
Yeah, I found that really interesting and we had a long chat
around the legal piece, which I'm interested in what she's going
to come back because I sent the manuscript.
So it's around the hospital stuff.
But yeah, yeah, but my I had loose extant do my first edit.
Yeah.
And I don't know if we talked about this Michelle, but her feedback
to me was you've really gone into this is what it feels like to
be in this place.
And this is what happened.
But she said it's not you're not accusing anybody in your
book.
But this is what could happen.
Yeah.
And then and then Natasha said, because I explained a few
things to her and she said, well, it could be like a nurse could
read it and say that was me.
And I did tell you this, you know, like, so.
So so you know how Kate had some similar feedback?
Kate Norbury.
Yeah, yeah.
And I suggested to her that she get legal advice.
He did. Yeah.
I might say the same thing to you.
Yeah.
Well, that's definitely it has to be read by legal.
And that's something that it feels like the kind's press has
that service because they actually send a manuscript through legal.
And they, yeah, they will give you some advice on that.
But you don't want anything distracting.
From your from your book, Nina.
Yeah, you don't want to kind of not deal with this now.
You don't want to be dealing with it later.
You want to know, and it's, you know, it's really interesting
because some of the things I write about, I, I ask myself
what, why, why am I, why, why am I telling this story?
Why is this important?
And it is always what always comes back to me is the this is
important for the reader in this situation.
And, and this will help the reader in this situation.
I've written 17 names and I shared this with both potential
publishers.
I don't even know if they're potential publishers, but
they are.
With 17 names of people that I still have used a Christian name.
So I, I still have to write those emails and ask people if they
want their Christian name or if they want me to change it.
Then some people in some cases I've changed, I've changed
a lot of names.
I've changed medical medical names.
I've changed the name of the hospital.
It's a fictitious name.
Okay.
But yeah.
Well, you're doing a lot of stuff already.
So that's good.
I would just say that I'd be listening to Natasha's view
before I'd be listening to Lou Sexton's because Lou,
Lou's an editor.
She's not a publisher.
It's a simple.
Yeah.
It was, it was feedback.
So, and I know, I know there's some things that are
sensitive and I'm sure she won't mind me saying her name.
Karen also faced this with her, with her book.
Yeah.
I guess when we're telling, if we're truth telling,
we're going to face these things.
Yeah.
Well, look, I, I made a decision to change a name.
Yes.
And I took out any identifying elements that anyone could kind
of work backwards and, you know, think that they worked it out.
There was no way.
The only way you could have worked it out is if you had
known me then, or you had known him then.
Now, the joke of that is, he's not a reader.
And 18 months after publishing, he sends me a shitty text
saying, I hear you've written a book and I hear you've
mentioned me.
I'm like, well, actually, I haven't mentioned you by name.
So I get another response and, and he's like, yes, but it,
you know, you've talked about me.
And I said, the only people who would possibly, and he said,
people have told me.
And I said, the only way people could identify you is if they
know you're capable of this toxic, violent behavior,
silence.
So if anyone was going to get legal on to me, it would have
been him, but he's, you know, he can't because he's put,
he puts himself in it if he does.
So the point was still made.
The story was still told.
I wasn't telling the story to get back at him or to illustrate
this is how you, these are the situations you can find yourself in.
I'm so sorry.
I'm going to have to jump off, but I really appreciate this
conversation.
And we're very helpful.
Yeah.
No, what timing.
What timing?
I'm slightly in shock because I kind of disliked it.
I can't even concentrate now.
So I need to like go and read the email and like, do you know what I mean?
Yeah.
I would definitely be doing that if I were you.
I understand.
I've sown down for like five minutes.
I don't even know what you're talking about.
Just keep breathing.
Yeah.
It's so exciting.
Congratulations.
Thank you.
That's close to a place.
I will do, I will do.
I'll be back in the chat and I just had a quick glance at it.
I was just saying like, deliver the first few chapters,
like very draft at the end of the month,
full manuscript in January, final manuscript in March.
And I was like, oh, actually that feels pretty good.
Like that, that probably actually feels right in terms of.
Having like,
being able to have a really good crack at the editing.
Yeah.
And not Russia.
Which is good.
And just have a look in there on that distribution.
Yes.
I understand that.
I will do.
All right.
Thanks so much.
Appreciate your time.
Hi.
Oh, yeah.
So.
I feel like even though I've shared the manuscript.
And I've,
and I shared this in my covering email to both people.
And they're, you know, they're aware there is still,
even though the manuscript reading,
there is still a little bit of work to do behind the scenes.
Yeah.
As you said with your character,
I do have a character like that in my book as well.
But,
but yeah,
how to maybe write that character with the script.
And without making that character so identifiable.
Yeah.
And it is tricky when it's a,
is that a personal relationship?
Yeah.
So it is tricky.
I mean, in my situation,
I hadn't told anybody what he'd done to me.
So it's not like,
it's not like people knew and could then,
it can be traced back anywhere.
But it's,
these situations are very different for each individual as to how you,
yeah.
That's what I mean.
The only people who could work out that it was him and he's capable of that
would be people who know who they experienced it.
Wow.
Yeah.
At least they're reading my book.
Exactly.
Yeah.
And so you,
you know three of us that have published with the coin press.
Yes.
Who do you know who's published with Bernard?
Um,
like,
is there anyone you can speak to,
to understand their experience with,
with that?
I can probably, yeah,
I probably can.
I was referred to her through somebody that knew of someone who had been
published.
Um,
What's,
what's my business called?
Um,
wait,
I've got it right.
I just found my notes.
Sorry.
Broad.
Oh,
broad.
Wait a minute.
Um,
broadcast.
Broadcast books.
I'm trying to work out why that name is so familiar.
Um,
and I'm just looking at the notes.
She did talk to me very much about the marketing really been up to
the author.
And I mean,
we are aware of that being in the EAC.
We are aware that we need to,
we need to do our own marketing and we need,
that's why I'm,
I'm posting at the moment on LinkedIn about this is happening.
You know,
I've written.
Yeah.
Good.
Absolutely.
Um,
and just to,
but not it's written.
It's not published.
It's written and I'm getting responses to that.
Um,
so she talked very much about that.
casting into potential.
Oh,
Scott Harris was a book.
She showed me.
Um,
and he's like on the speaking circuit.
about casting into potential.
So,
um,
yeah,
he had an accident,
life changing accident.
And,
yeah.
And he's,
um,
on the speaking circuit.
So she showed me his book.
Um,
I haven't got.
This was quite some time ago that I met her.
The,
the manuscript wasn't even finished when I met her.
Um,
and then she talked about,
she did talk about her distribution through booktopia.
Yeah.
And look,
it's different now since,
since I,
um,
I'm just turning a look at the books that she's published.
Had you thought about.
Major street.
Like,
like,
so when you,
when you reach out to the kind press and to broadcast books.
Or,
this is,
you know,
customs going to have going to publish books.
Um,
this is, you know,
customs going to have going to be the way I'm going.
Hmm.
A conscious decision.
Um,
I didn't.
I just know that it's,
because I'm not known.
Like I'm not,
I'm not a celebrity writing about something that happened to me.
And,
and I know that it will be very difficult to go through,
um,
traditional.
Yeah.
Publishing.
Um,
and the only reason I mention it is.
Mark Barrage,
who's been in the EAC for a long time.
Yeah, I've spoken with Mark. Yeah.
So,
and what did,
what was his experience with major street like?
Okay.
I spoke to Mark probably my first week at the EAC,
which was.
Which is two years ago.
So,
um,
yeah,
we are.
Yeah.
I've been in the EAC for a long time.
And,
yeah,
we are.
Yeah.
So his book comes under the heading of what Kelly would call stealth
help.
Yeah, that's what, yeah.
Yeah.
And so it's sounding like the way you've written yours now is
that crossover between self-help and stealth help.
So he has a summary at the end of each chapter and some
questions and so on.
He,
um,
he's the one who had a bike accident.
Yep.
And so it's the story of potentially becoming a
paraplegic through to walking again.
Yeah.
And so,
Leslie,
Leslie Williams,
who's connected to the EAC.
Um,
I don't know,
have a look at the catalogue of major street.
Um,
Karen Stein published with them.
And I know it's a different kind of book, but, um,
I know it's just a thought,
but if you're happy with Bernard Deyton Natasha and it comes
in, it depends what your budget is, of course, as well.
Yeah.
So, um,
yeah, well, it's,
that's something I have to, um,
consider.
Yeah.
As well.
I mean,
I have to consider.
Um,
and then,
and I mean,
I looked at who I pitched to.
Yeah.
Through my three pictures.
And, um,
and I looked at the feedback that I'd got from my pictures
and I just looked at,
um,
where it was really positive and I reached out to
Natasha.
I reached out to someone else who didn't even come back to
me in the EAC context.
Right.
So, um,
but yeah, I'm happy to,
I'm happy to explore Major Street.
Yeah.
Well, just have a look and see what you think.
Um,
and,
um,
and I don't quite know how they work to be honest.
And I'm not sure about their distribution either,
but I just know that Mark's book sounds a little similar
to how you've got yours.
So it might be worth a conversation anyway.
Um,
so have a look.
Leslie did a session.
There'll be a video in the vault somewhere of Leslie talking
about publishing in, in Circle.
So just search Leslie Williams and it, you should find the link
for that easily enough.
Um,
Oh, something else I was going to ask you then about.
Oh, I know.
In terms of your business,
like how do you,
how are you going to use your book?
Is it going to be anything to do with your business?
Yeah, it will.
It definitely will become part of the ecosystem.
Yes.
Because my business, um, is about coaching,
um, particularly emerging leaders,
but I'm actually doing a talk tomorrow,
um, on what I'm calling inside out leadership.
So it's understanding who you are as a person and understanding
who's in your team.
And this is a lot of this is linked to the work I do with
Gallup and the work I do with values as well.
And I use the story of having cancer and having the rug pulled
beneath me and the point I make in, um, in this,
in the talk I'm doing tomorrow is that I didn't know who I was
without my business card.
And all of a sudden I was told I couldn't work
and I was going to be in hospital and I had no idea
when I was going to go back into the workforce.
There was no timeline and the timeline became much longer
than I ever expected.
Now I talk, I tell that story in my book and I finish the
book with what I do today.
Yeah, great.
Great.
So it is definitely part of the ecosystem and the
exercises that I use in the book are exercises that I use
in my business or tools that I use in my business.
Excellent.
Good.
In that case then I think it's worth just doing a little
investigating with Leslie just.
I will.
Yeah.
She has there who does this now just so that you can get
another three are three is enough to be considering.
You don't want to go any broader, but you've got to
get a similar.
Get a different.
Different perspective.
Yeah.
Okay.
It's on.
I feel like, yeah, there is.
Oh God, you know how you know what it's like Michelle,
you work it, you re-work it, you re-work it.
Yeah.
And you re-work it.
So I feel like there is definitely going to be
changes.
But the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the
the, the, the product is there now.
Yeah.
Absolutely.
So no more editing.
Not, not from me, but there will be another edit for
sure.
No, there will be.
But what I'm saying is don't invest in another
editor.
No, no, no.
The next editor needs to be with who you're
publishing with.
Yeah.
Definitely.
Now I thought about that and I've probably had
some conversations in this network about that.
And my, and I came to the fact that I've had one
edit.
I took the feedback from that edit.
I did, I did the edit again myself and now I've
got a product.
Yeah.
You don't, it doesn't need to be perfect.
The point at this point, unless you're going to
go and,
Yeah.
You can stop at office works and sell it that way.
No.
When you go.
The next thing is to really work out Nina.
What is most important for you?
Is a distribution.
Is it working with somebody that you feel
you're being heard, you can ask questions.
Yeah.
You've got to partner with whoever the publisher is.
And it is it publishing with someone that does have
some level of marketing or PR as part of the
package.
Yeah.
What's, what's going to be most important for you
and how you use your book.
Yeah.
And having a look at things like what will the
commission be?
That's not what it's called.
What will the royalties be?
How does that differ?
How is that calculated?
Is that something that's important to you?
Is selling a thousand books important to you?
Or is it getting your books into the right hands
so that you can get $10,000 worth of work out of it?
Is that more important?
Is that the way you're going to be using your book?
Well, it's, yeah.
For a start, I think distribution, distribution is
important because why write it?
And if I don't have, if I don't have support with
marketing, it's not going to get into the hands
of the avatar.
Correct.
No, it's, it's almost like, and I'm writing, I'm
already talking to some of the cancer related
bodies, if you're out there to get ideas about
how to get that out to the avatar.
So from that point of view, distribution, I mean,
I've spoken to people that, look, I spoke to
somebody that said they were happy to distribute
100 books.
Do you know, it was the point of writing it.
I've had people saying to me, you know, is it just
the process of writing the story?
And that's not it.
It's the process of sharing the story.
So it might really help another person.
That's in that situation.
So that's distribution.
When we're talking about the investment, the next
stage, there's going to be an investment,
which every person has known.
Yes.
And what is most important?
And it sounds to me like it is part of your
business.
Yes.
And is that where your readers are?
I don't know.
I'm just asking.
No, no, no.
So not really, Michelle.
So my reader, my first avatar is someone that's
unwell.
That's not my business.
But they are at work.
Yeah.
Well, this affects, cancer affects two out of
three Australians.
Yeah.
Which really means it affects every Australian.
Correct.
That's right.
But so do many of the things that we talk about at
the EAC.
So the first reader is someone that's unwell and
they're carer to understand this process.
So that is the book I've written to how to help
somebody.
Something that's come up along the way and
writing this book that I was a young person in the
well, younger than I am now in the, in the, in the,
in the, a really important projectory of my own
career.
And that was taken from under me.
So then it was what I did with that to turn that
around.
And that's, I guess that's the second avatar
which is linked to my business.
And the, how this is linked to the
ecosystem of my business is what I've done to
create this business and my why, my why behind the
business.
Hmm.
Okay.
So, so there's two, I guess, if that might sound
complicated, but from my business, it, it gives
me credibility.
It's like, this is what I've done to create the
business and this is where it came from.
And these are tools that I now use in coaching.
Hmm.
That's a different avatar to you're in, in cancer,
you've got cancer, you're in hospital and you're
really, really scared.
Yeah.
So I think it's really working out kind of the
priority of those two drivers for you.
Yeah.
Of the worth of the investment and the decision
and where distribution feeds into that.
Yeah.
Really, yeah, definitely.
And I guess the partnership piece, because it
is a very personal story, I guess it has to be
somebody that sees value in that story being a
book.
That's where that piece.
Yeah.
Because there are many, I mean, the reason I asked
you about Bernard Dech, and because I've got a
book here somewhere.
I've got so many books here, it's ridiculous, but
who dancing with cancer was her book and it
was published.
This is someone I knew through another
business.
I mean touring business, I was involved with a
couple of years ago and she published, I don't
think it was broadcast books, but it was again.
And she just wanted to tell her story.
She's not using it in any other way.
But my point is there are a number of, you know,
we've got Anne Gaetley who was in the EAC.
So there are a number of books, people writing
books around similar journeys, but yours has this
other element.
It's not, you know, the way you've structured
your chapters and so on.
So it's finding someone who understands that and
understands the potential of how that might
separate your book.
The point is, is it sitting on a memoir
shelf or is it sitting on a self-help
shelf?
And so you don't need to answer me now.
I've been told by most of them, I think it's
alongside Mark's book, it's self-help.
Yeah.
I mean, every time I've pitched from, in EAC,
that's the feedback I've had.
I didn't even know what that was when I first
got that feedback.
Well, it's an EAC thing.
That automatically gives you a kind of a
broader range because possibly, again, you've got
to think about it.
You've got to go into bookshops and imagine
where's your book going to sit and all of that
kind of stuff.
Yeah.
All right.
So we're coming up at the end of the 90
minutes and I've just realised that this is
still recording, well, you know, because the
whole thing is recorded.
So I don't think we've said anything.
Okay.
So stay in touch.
Let me know how you go, what you decide.
It's an exciting time.
Thanks for all your feedback, Michelle.
I really appreciate it along the way.
Just a little, the little notes, you know what
it's like when, you know, we fall into
self-doubt and it's like we're writing
and we're working on something and, yeah,
you're in your own head so much of the time
with this.
Yeah.
I would not have done it without the EAC.
I would not have done it.
And just getting those little notes along the
way and I know you've read little pieces and,
yeah, the little notes of encouragement that
say, keep going, this is going to be a value
to somebody.
And I do want it to be a value to somebody.
It's going to be.
Yeah.
I don't know what it's going to be.
Again, it's not going to be for everybody.
No, it's not everyone's book.
Julie's Dancing with Cancer isn't for everybody.
No.
It wasn't for me.
It didn't resonate with me.
But it's doing a very different thing to
your book, which is a very different thing to
Anne Gaetley's book.
She's on a mission.
Yeah.
Those are some of the things that are in
your book.
Yeah.
Karen's book is completely different again in a
different audience.
Yes.
But we need all of these books for the
different audiences.
Yeah, we do.
That's why you've got to keep going and do it.
Yeah.
So these are very good questions.
And anyway, I'm on a different stage of the
journey.
You are now.
You are.
Yeah.
And again, you know, you need to work out.
You can't listen to everybody.
Like you can't do what everybody.
You've got to work out which of these pieces of
advice are relevant for my book.
And I still have to remember that now or two
years after.
I'm still reminding myself, but that's not.
I see someone doing something with their book.
Yeah, but that's not that's not my book.
Yeah.
That's not relevant to me and my book.
And what?
Yeah.
We've just got to keep our own.
In our lane.
Stay in our lane.
Yeah.
And I think to give myself advice, I have to be
very clear about the lane.
Very clear about the lane.
I hear that it's a double lane.
It's a two.
Don't worry about what's going on on the
auto bar next to you.
Don't worry about that.
Yeah.
Okay.
All right.
Thanks for the chat.
Thanks.
Bye.
Bye, doll.